último dirigente vivo de los gemelos
rojos espera en silla de ruedas la
sentencia este jueves el tribunal
especial de Camboya para juzgar los
crímenes ocurridos durante la dictadura
de los gemelares rojos confirmó la
condena San Juan de 91 años por
genocidio el tribunal supremo anuncia
que condena aquí usan a cadena perpetua
y confirma la decisión del tribunal
inferior
los gérmenes rojos instauraron un
régimen socialista entre 1975 y 1979 que
se conoció como la República democrática
de capuchea eran el brazo armado del
partido comunista y su rostro más
violento
Durante los cuatro años de gobierno los
gemeres mataron a casi 2 millones de
camboyanos su objetivo de crear un
hombre puro con ideología maoísta
terminó en campos de concentración
matrimonios forzados y Éxodo en un
contexto de guerra fría que enfrentó en
su momento a la Camboya comunista con su
vecino capitalista Vietnam del sur
apoyado económica y militarmente por
Estados Unidos
sobrevivientes y familiares de las
víctimas del régimen acudieron a los
estrados
estoy feliz la sentencia es la correcta
que usan pan era el líder por lo tanto
debe ser encarcelado de por vida el
vicepre Primer Ministro de Camboya instó
a que este tribunal sea un ejemplo para
juzgar otras masacres en el sudeste
asiático Este modelo de tribunal es
reconocido internacionalmente como un
tribunal híbrido para el juzgamiento de
crímenes y masacres Debería ser
promovido para enjuiciar crímenes graves
en la escena internacional y
especialmente a nivel regional
el juzgado fue Claro en señalar que kius
and fan tenía conocimiento directo de
los crímenes de lesa humanidad